the jurgen experience then i wonder when
they started doing drug tests like when
did they first start i think i think 80s
i don't think they did it in the 70s
you know i don't think so um no they
probably didn't have drug tests back
then yeah you know back then i bet coke
was real coke you got coke i bet it was
clean yeah they probably didn't even now
you can't [ __ ]
can't touch it what does it say here
president ronald reagan worst workplace
drug testing started off after president
ronald reagan required it for federal
employees in 1986
and it peaked during the drug war of the
1990s
[ __ ] reagan
86 yeah
he probably saw daryl strawberry.good
and he's like enough of this [ __ ]
that was the first steroids of sports
was the coke of sports because they all
did it right well i bet get baseball
players apparently they all like to do
uh amphetamines that was gonna say yeah
yeah that was dope yeah
well baseball players that's probably
one of the most performance-enhanced
sports yeah with with all the [ __ ]
steroids and the the apparently they all
like uh
adhd medication
yeah something about it makes you focus
and and what it does is too you play
through injury you don't feel the injury
so you have you have a little tear so
guys that were at the plate if they had
a little tear in their elbow and
shoulder didn't wow it didn't matter and
their hand-eye coordination was that's
why barry bonds
barry bonds was so barry bonds hall of
famer before he did it then he saw
everybody doing it and then he did it
again i was sitting
courtside nick i got hammered at the i
uh
uh i'm good friends pete davidson is a
good friend of mine and he was at snl he
goes dude come down we got to take and
i'm a die hard knicks for die hard
knicks because i'm a yankees giants but
i've won with them my my problem child
is the is the knicks and i got my son
into it and [ __ ] and we go down and i'm
sitting next to this guy and he's got
his hair slicked back and everybody's
coming up to him and he's got the beard
and i'm looking at this guy and i'm
drinking [ __ ] they just pour vodkas and
i'm just i'm [ __ ] hammered courtside
and this guy and i know this guy is so
at halftime they take you back to
everybody's drinking and eating so
finally like yeah the guy you're sitting
next to is um the mets the new manager
the mets mickey calloway and i was like
oh okay cool that's who it is so we just
start talking we're shooting the [ __ ]
and everything and i go all right and
i'm hammered now so now i like all of
the what you shouldn't do i'm doing yeah
i go can i ask you a question he goes
please please he's a nice guy
best baseball he was uh before he was a
mets manager he was a pitching coach for
the indians
and now the guardians which is [ __ ]
awful name
but um
he said uh like who's the best baseball
player you've ever seen live in all of
the years you've been in baseball and he
just leaves back and he goes oof
and then he just goes oh barry bonds he
goes nobody in history made a pitcher
pay for a mistake more he goes if a
pitcher made one [ __ ] mistake by an
inch over
so imagine that guy on roids and he was
imagine yeah
yeah yeah he was but he was that guy he
was that guy before
and then he was on it right so now
there's barry bonds monster barry bonds
no injuries
no you know nothing's going to stop him
hand-eye coordination better more power
that guy
yeah i mean how many
they all did it right
mark maguire sammy sosa they were all on
the sauce you could kind of look at the
ones that did a certain way because they
were square
i was in a [ __ ] elevator with gary
sheffield i was like he was like a book
dresser he was like a [ __ ] he was
just just you could tell that these guys
were just different i met kenseiko in
1986
i was uh
a fitness trainer at uh the boston
athletic club i'd like to teach people
how to lift weights and [ __ ] and uh oh
yeah jose canseco came in like the peak
of his popularity he was a [ __ ] giant
he was so big
i couldn't believe how big he was like i
i knew he was you know you see him on tv
he's an athlete but you see him in real
life he's like 260 pounds it was [ __ ]
huge yeah gigantic actually i don't know
if sheffield did it but he looked like
that i don't know if
who got who was the big oh then the guys
that denied it in front of congress oh
what happens with them did they go to
jail for that you know it was funny
everybody that admitted it was it was
like okay but the guys that were like
remember rafael pomero he goes i he
[ __ ] like pointed at the guy he goes
i never never and like he did
the problem with that is if you lie
about something like that so
emphatically no one's ever gonna believe
you again like if you get an argument
with your wife i was with tommy we went
to the [ __ ] game i drove straight
home i got stuck in traffic get him
that's the point pointing i get him yeah
he looks like he's on roy's right there
that's probably why he's pointing oh
there's a [ __ ] there's a bobblehead
doll of him pointing
and what i've never used steroids
mark mcguire did mark mcguire did this
one he just goes they go mark did you do
you know did you use steroids in this
and he just goes i'm not here to talk
about you know the past i'm here to talk
about the future and that was his way of
just being like let's let's clean the
game up
nice yeah after i've made my money let's
clean the game up let's bring
everybody's home runs down to a normal
manageable level
yeah my wife knows that i'm lying dude
she's my wife and i've been together for
[ __ ] 20 almost 20 years and married
almost 15. and when she has me dead to
rights she just looks and we both know
don't do steroids in front of her then
no
or don't lie about it
those guys like if you think about it
they made baseball more interesting
though like it's so stupid that they
busted them for that they should have
been just like everybody shut the [ __ ]
up everybody shut the [ __ ] up you
brought baseball back but why did they
make a big deal out of it who gives a
[ __ ] if they're doing steroids i just
think when it goes from 40 home runs is
a good season to 90 it's just
people getting better
cars are getting faster
now
why did it go to congress though it's
pretty weird it went all the way i think
it shouldn't go because baseball's our
national game that's why because like if
that happened with like pick a sport
darts do you think anybody give a [ __ ]
dart players are doing roids you know
bring them to congress [ __ ] bocce
ball players yeah yeah like why is it
that it's got to be that baseball's a
national sport i don't think they would
have done that with anything else they
definitely would have done with football
because they know everybody's juiced up
on football
you